in the world of steep you take to the
mountain with your snowboard wingsuit
skis or paraglider exploring a massive
open world playground populated with
other real players that's full of twists
turns and surprises at 15,000 feet you
can see beyond the curvature of the
earth a sane person would never find
themselves on these Peaks but risk
takers limit breakers drop in
take in the sights as you shred the
world's most insane terrain conquer the
mountain with your friends sharing every
great moment by uploading it to YouTube
Twitter or any of your favorite social
channels every run you make creates a
line that can be shared in game to
challenge anyone anywhere looking for
inspiration check out the many
challenger bents and mountain stories
blanketing the landscape increasing your
reputation unlocks new legendary drop
zones allowing you access to uncharted
peaks and special areas and let's not
forget about the ultra-competitive
Invitational challenges a high rep comes
with additional perks like hot air
balloons and highly exclusive helicopter
drops both of which offer the high
altitude necessary to take on the most
harrowing lines in the world being the
best means looking your best so you want
to pick gear that stands out in the
crowd while you're out crushing the
mountain you'll naturally develop into
six unique play styles so have fun out
there
as you discover your talents steep will
continue to grow and expand adding free
downloadable updates including a
daunting new mountain Alaska as well as
exciting free content mirroring
real-life events like the freeride world
tour and community tournaments the
mountains of weight so grab your friends
and your gear explore everywhere shred
any line share everything this is steep
drop in